where are the armed men who come in to
take the protesters away where are they
this kind of behavior is never
tolerating in Baka you shout like that
they they put you in jail right away no
trial no no nothing journalists we have
a special jail for journalists you're
stealing right to jail you're playing
music too loud right to jail right away
you're driving too fast jail slow jail
you're charging too high prices for
sweaters glasses you ride to jail you
undercook fish believe it or not jail
you overcook chicken also jail undercook
overcook you make an appointment with a
dentist and you don't show up Believe It
or Not jail right away we have the best
patience in the world because of jail
now I know your gentleman had a long
flight but I have prepared a welcome
party in your honor excellent I like to
party well my job is to see to your
every need do we just uh select the
woman we
desire I will take the large black one
interesting choice did you have some
kind of a book with photos of the women
available to us if not I will also take
the sexy black
one I am not surprised at all I've been
to South America I did very well
there Jess and we two are pleased to be
here in your dirty Alleyway we thank you
for the container of sap me bag of
garbage his English isn't perfect so I
don't think he realizes how insulting
he's being we also sister cities with
Kong North Korea
their town is far nicer we haven't been
here for a very long time but what we
have seen is really from the bottom of
our hearts truly
depressing really really sad stuff it's
funny because Antonio said to me can't
we turn this car around and say we're
sick or something or that we lost our
way of course that would be rude to
you the banana you wanted Sor finally
Juke what with your hands you peel the
banana okay let's get started shall we I
have a full day of activities planned I
would like to see where the children are
fed the
sweeteners a restaurant American
children are fattened more efficiently
than any other children in the world I
mean they're like little basketballs I
mean they're huge you know Brokers okay
I do not understand you've never had a
budget
[Laughter]
shortage no Venezuela is blessed with
massive oil reserves massive I mean
tremendous like you not believe the
state sells the oil and keeps all the
money and we build whatever we want wow
well now I do not
understand I feel like my English was
very clear should I repeat Venezuela
Venezuela my country has a lot of oil
oil is food for cars everybody doing
okay back there comfortable
well the motel we're putting you up in
is really nice you can watch TBS do you
have tbs in Venezuela I have everything
in
Venezuela I have four satellite dishes
in my estate we get 14,000
channels
14,000 I already know who wins Project
Runway wow I'm coming over to your house
then I see what you're getting at but no
thank you I'm still primarily interested
in the large black
woman in Mora the government moves like
a like a hot knife through butter I to
sit here listen to people yelling these
fat faces turning all red are you
kidding me we're like kings we walk down
the street and they treat us like rock
stars we answer to nobody well in a true
democracy we believe that the input of
our citizens is extremely valuable
hey these pretzels
suck thank you
see no wonder nothing ever gets done in
this country really nothing gets done
tell that to the Golden Gate Bridge or
American Idol or the moon oh wait you
can't cuz you've never been there look
this is not personal we just think that
you are weak and your city is
disgusting I think you're rude and I
think you've been rude since you came
here and I think that your medals are
stupid and your uniform is lame and you
guys want to marry Hugo Chavez hey
do not disrespect Chavez stupid
Chavez I just told you not to disrespect
good I just did that's twice I don't
like Chavez yes you do and do not
disrespect it no I don't yes you do no I
don't Raul look if you don't like it
here then go okay Raul great good shut
up we shutting up yeah here we
go L those are our pens right you don't
even need them great then don't take
them I would just like to First say I am
so sorry for blowing up yesterday it was
completely uncalled for well we are
sorry as well we were very tired from
our long journey also we were a bit
jealous our colleagues from Caracas are
visiting their sister city of Miami yeah
they've been partying with Dwayne W they
sent us all these photos and and
QuickTime files I mean you have to see
this place Miami I mean just gorgeous
everything there's so much soul and life
everywhere every little tiny street so
much culture and history and the cars
people really take care of their cars
no little older but still just beautiful
sort of really really nice and the food
so spicy and wonderful we could not even
believe it but Pony is really good as
well just ah Leslie hello R the mayor
will be with us in just a few minutes if
you don't mind we would like to take a
video of you to show our superiors oh
okay sure did you have the check that we
gave to you uh yes I
do okay we going to show it to the
camera and say uh how much it is and
what it is
for okay this is a check for
$35,000 and it is to build a park how
generous yes it's really generous now
say Viva
Venezuela Viva Venezuela via
Chavez thank you Venezuela via Chavez
say ah come
on I I don't want to Viva that guy we
just give you $355,000 that's worth from
viva via
Chavez yes VI
Chavez what is he
saying they are very happy they say Hugo
Chavez will love this video because it
is another success for their committee
committee yeah their committee to
humiliate and shame
America it'll be a good video the
committee to humiliate and shame America
yes it is Hugo chave passion project oh
we just had an idea why don't you call
the Park after Chavez you know you call
Ug Chavez park and you can have a nice
big Fountain of his head so that when
the water is coming out he's spitting at
you all the time
you should write this
down Viva America Viva Pony Viva mayor
Walter Gunderson you have offended us
you have offended the government of
Baraka you are no longer our
sister what Happ so are you guys ready
we're about to start this is where you
have your meetings well the location
rotates sometimes we have them on the
volleyball
Court where do you hold your meetings
well now that you asked uh we usually
rotate as well between different
fortresses and citadels and
palaces we don't need
palaces the ideas are what shine in our
meetings what are you some kind of
why don't you have hand dryers in the
park bathrooms they's so much more
sanitary than paper towels anyone knows
that my dog went to one of your parks
and ate another dog's feces then I'm
going to sue you for that how do you
like it h how do you like that now
imagine you're holding coffee this is
outrageous where are the armed men who
come in to take the protesters away
where are they this kind of behavior is
never tolerating in Baraka you shout
like that they they put you in jail
right away no trial no no nothing
journalists we have a special jail for
journalists you're stealing right to
jail you're playing music too loud right
to jail right away you're driving too
fast jail slow jail you're charging too
high prices for sweaters glasses you
ride to jail you undercook fish Believe
It or Not jail you overcook chicken also
jail undercook overcook you make an
appointment with a dentist and you don't
show up Believe It or Not jail right
away we have the best patience in the
world because of
jail
that